[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where
two lifelong best friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
continuing our conversation about the
enneagram
i do think that if you didn't listen to
the last episode you should listen to it
before this one but
if you're not the kind of person that
wants to do that if you're an eight an
enneagram eight and you're like screw
you i'm going to do what i want to do
then you can listen to this one it's
fine because i do think it will stand
alone we're going to be talking more
about
how the numbers relate to each other
specifically how a three that's me a one
that's linked relate to each other some
of the strengths and the weaknesses in
that pairing and we'll also talk a
little bit about
some other relationships in our lives
probably just our marriages
and uh and then maybe what we can do to
grow
based on what we've learned that sounds
like a good plan i will measure the
success of this podcast based on that
criteria
at the end i'm sure you will before we
uh get any further we do want to remind
you that episode four
of ron statt is out now and in this
episode ronstat
and faye his love interest uh finally
get some alone time
all right yeah so if you're into
you know a long time people getting
alone time and listening to it
uh episode four is for you of course
listen to episodes one two and three
before you get to
is that where the mouth sounds came in
uh actually i think the mouth sounds
coming a little bit later
but boy well there are some mouth sounds
oh my goodness
i'm glad i wasn't there for the
recording of those mouth sounds i heard
about it
yeah i think i think we have some b-roll
footage maybe at some point we're
releasing
not but we're not gonna cut to it now
nope no no um
i wanted to kick this thing off just by
talking about
how i how i've been thinking about the
previous episode
um it just struck me you know i had to
and i mentioned in the episode that i
had to go to the dentist
right after we recorded last week's
episode
and and i so i the appointment was
pretty close to the end of the episode
as a matter of fact
i knew i had to be there so i was kind
of like
shutting down the making the decisions
like hey
i got to get out of here let's we got to
start wrapping this thing up so
in in as graceful a way as possible
i tried to get us to that point so that
i could get to my dentist appointment
and then when the show was over i
immediately left got my car and like
rushed over there and i just started to
observe
because i was totally in the headspace
of observing my oneness
that the entire way to the
to the dentist i was just just
beating myself up about and ending the
podcast and analyzing it well that was
that's where it started
like i was like i really don't like how
i had to
truncate our conversation and you know
if if rhett did that to me i would feel
like you know
that i was being rushed and that instead
of processing and having like a nice
gentle landing to the podcast which is
always important to me we had to rush it
and i just felt like
man this is my fault and i'm like
driving down the road i'm like you know
i'm going to text rhett right now
i just want to apologize wow for having
to
you know having to speed through the
ending and i think the reason why i
wanted to do that is a very one reason
and that's okay i didn't meet
the standard of how i wanted how i
envisioned the episode wrapping up
what it would not necessarily what would
be said but what it would feel like
that that was actually the criteria that
that i felt like
was missing i didn't like that i didn't
like i
you know i assumed that you were
thinking the exact same thing but i was
projecting that
and i was like i want to apologize
because i want to
pre-acknow i want to acknowledge that i
know that
so instead of receiving the criticism
later
because that'll really hurt that really
hurts the one when it's
hey this wasn't this wasn't good enough
this didn't meet the standard it's like
okay yes i knew that i was going to say
that first
you know so that that was the first
thing and then i start getting into the
whole
you know and i'm sitting there and by
the time i get to the dentist
i'm experiencing this this anger this
frustration
and i sit down and she hands me an ipad
and she's like i know you've been
you broke it i know you think what
almost you broke it over your knee she
was like i know you've been coming here
for years but
um we are on a new system and i need you
to re-enter all your information
in again oh that makes you mad and i was
like
seriously and so it's like create a
username
create a password oh this is the worst
thing and i'm like okay i'm supposed to
create a password on your
device how am i supposed to store that
password i have a system for storing my
passwords
so that they i don't have to remember
what they are and they're all unique
yeah this is bad news for a one and then
i open up my app to
to to create the password and then i'm
going to manually transfer it to their
dumb
ipad that's the worst so and then what
maybe maybe there's
maybe they'll have my password i don't
know yeah and you've accidentally used
it for something else the next thing you
know your dental hygienist
is getting money from your bank account
yes siphoning my bank account
i have trust issues i don't trust
hygienists you know they say
if you if you spend that much time in
somebody else's mouth
something's got to happen to your brain
to your morale if there's anybody you
should trust as someone who's shoving
both hands in your mouth i think they've
gained so much trust from people that
they exploit it
my app my password app wouldn't work
i tried it three four times i'm sitting
there and now i'm just steaming
and i say you know i stood up and i and
i said you know what
can we just do this next time i'm just
i'm having a day that makes it where i
be i'm basically incapable of
creating of filling out this information
this reminds me of the time my mom
took my kids to the place the trampoline
place where you jump
yeah and you know how you have to like
fill out a computer screen that just
like registers the child there and says
that there's a waiver right it's your
fault
yeah she got to that screen because my
kids tell the story they're like
mom and dad got to the screen and she
started realizing she was gonna have to
like put our names in the screen and she
was like
y'all do this she's like i'm not about
to do this
yeah i had gotten to such a i i'd
gone into super anal critical mode in
analysis mode
of the last episode that
i mean the app didn't work that wasn't
my fault
and but it kind of saved me because i'm
gonna i'm gonna switch dentists anyway
after that i don't want to put my
information in here this is a good point
to break off from you guys well you've
been talking we go to the same dentist
and you've been talking about it
well the hygienist switching again the
hygienist doesn't follow
the strict protocols that i've come to
uh
expect because when you there's no
flossing the last time i went she didn't
floss
well that's your job but she told when
you told me that you were thinking about
switching i was like
this would never cross my mind that i
would switch
dentists unless like the dentist was you
know like asking me to commit crimes or
something
but and then i told jesse i was like
link's thinking about
he thinks we should we this dennis is
bad now
and i'm like and she's like how
like both of us couldn't understand i
can't answer that question okay
i want to hear the pitch for why i
should switch well because i've
experienced
meticulous dentistry where they're like
they're measuring your gums
and they're like flossing your teeth and
like
uh again giving you lectures on your gum
health
and the last two times i went none of
that happened or maybe you've improved
maybe maybe you've gotten better there
was no assessment hmm well i got an
assessment last time
and it was bad it changed my it changed
my ways man and
i floss every day because people in
there are different
they've changed and and they're
literally different they're literally
different people
and i think it's changed hands and they
don't have the same procedures
okay all right and i wanna i wanna feel
the pain because i wanna know
that i've done everything i could to
for for my for my health i want i want
their
i want them to hold themselves to the
highest standard because only then can i
relax
what am i hold on i'm walking out and
they didn't do this that me
teeth gonna fall out it is a very one
thing right
yeah and plus they weren't really they
also weren't that nice
oh okay interesting well i wasn't
thinking any of that
about the episode uh i was not thinking
uh i would you know i was thinking a lot
of other things too but
here's the interesting thing there was
one thing
there was one thing that i was thinking
i'm gonna save it
uh i'm gonna save it until we get into
the conversation about ones and threes
because i was like it's interesting when
i read about this because i
felt this at the at one point
during the episode and it's the only i
mean it's not really a criticism it's
just
it's so something you said that made me
feel a certain way that i think is
indicative of the one and the three
yeah but i was not thinking at all
about you cutting the conversation off
because i knew that you had to go
and i know and we had a part two and i
also
was not um
thinking about like oh that didn't go
well or that could have been better
but what i was thinking apart from what
i'm gonna get to later
is i can tell that link is having a
difficult time
with the this podcast
there's tension yeah because any time
there
it's not just a conversation and it's
like there's information that needs to
be presented
and even like so we typically don't have
many conversations about the
conversation that we're going to have
right but when we're going to present
information
it's one thing i'm just like okay this
is your episode where you're going to
talk about your
deconstruction story yeah and then it's
just like it's all in your head and it's
all on your plate and you just do it
and then vice versa and we kind of know
that the other guy is there to be
supportive and to be a listener
but there are fewer and far more and
further between
there are these episodes where it's like
i've got something and you've got
something and we have to coordinate
the presentation yeah and every
conversation we have about that is
tense there's a tension in that
conversation and i'm like
link is really he's very tense about
us coordinating this podcast
presentation
yes and it's like and i and i want you
to just relax
i want you to i want you to just relax
so you can enjoy it getting on the same
page
is what i think gets me to that point
and if it's
and if that doesn't happen well this is
the other thing that i said i wasn't
going to go into but like
we should go into this yeah you're
exactly
maybe we should maybe we should move
ahead and talk about the threes and the
ones because i think it actually will
illuminate the con
for people who are like what are you
guys talking about you seem crazy seem
like a couple of dental hygienists
i'm really throwing dental hygienists
under the bus i love them they're great
i don't think they're criminals they
don't get enough credit because
the dentist just comes in and like looks
at your teeth and like gives a thumbs up
dinners are suckers
they're the ones who suck he brings out
a couple of tools yeah right
but it's the hygienist that does the
real i mean all that measuring all the
stuff
that i'm critical of is of the hygienist
because
like they're the key in my mind right
right right um
and yeah i did vent some of this
to christy and you like you talked to
jesse i talked to christy
and then jenna came by and since she was
sitting in the room like
christy was like i got it you know
link's not happy about
the episode and uh i was actually
encouraged jenna what you said was very
helpful because what she said was
i thought it was just a classic
exhibition of each of your numbers
in full force in that episode and that's
and that made me feel better
because i felt like it redeemed
everything that i was critical of
because
it was like i was critical of things
where it's like oh i was too controlling
or
this didn't or you didn't meet my
expectation
or my standard and or didn't go the way
that i felt
you know all of that i i'm i'm
assuming as they listened there was like
a smile on people's faces that was like
because jenna said this they we don't
even know how
much we are like going into our numbers
you know yeah we're very we're some
people are not as pronounced
and they're not so selfish it's so
ironic that we were talking about it
yet having this level of like i was more
aware of it but still
it's it's it's a lot of work to be aware
and to um to respond to and i think
that's the other thing
through the lens of our number
interactions that we can talk about
like our paths to growth and
integrating this this information yeah
but let's take a
a quick break to talk about the uh the
hat right there
okay the mythical trucker hat this is my
favorite
we actually requested that this be made
because
let's just be honest uh we were making
hats
in the mythical store that were
uh and we still are they're like dad
hats right and they're the cool hats
that the kids wear
right but we are actually dads and so
dads don't wear dad hats dance irony
dads wear
old-school high crown trucker hats that
are made of foam
and when it gets hot it's got built-in
ac
right i mean this is a classic cat uh
and it if you throw it overboard your
dad boat it floats
it floats well i think it floats for a
while until it until it maybe 20 minutes
kind of like a sponge
mythical.com um
i thought we could just start reading
through
the this relationship description any
the enneagram institute
has a really uh again i've already
plugged the website but i love the
website because of the way it's
organized and it's simple
and you don't have to read a book to
kind of understand the basics of the
enneagram
but one of the things that they have is
this section
under the learn tab where
it says relationships
and then you can click on your type and
then you can click on
the type another type and see how those
two types
interact and so this is the enneagram
one
the reformer that's link with the
enneagram
three the achiever that's me
and if you click on and it doesn't
matter whether you go from one to three
or three to one it goes to the same page
okay good uh because i could tell that
you were you were like are we going are
we doing
that i was just curious if one's first
is it is that something different
it just it it i mean it has them in
numerical order on each page
read through and i'll a minute or or
i'll be like maybe not yeah we'll just
see
where we relate and when we get to the
thing that i was talking about earlier
i'll tell you what it was
maybe maybe you'll anticipate it
enneagram ones
and threes are both competent
serious-minded
and idealistic yes this serious-minded
thing
which i think we've shared a little bit
before okay yes we're comedians
and we may cut the fool constantly
uh as we interact with each other in
front of
you but as jenna could probably tell you
this
um if you just hang out with us as we're
doing
our work it's not fun we're not our
creative process is not fun we're not
like these fun happy-go-lucky guys
constantly making jokes
constantly laughing like it is like two
people
working on a serious problem even if
it's a really dumb thing that we're
working on i'll go beyond that i'll say
even when we are just hanging out with
our friends
if if a mythical beast were to hang out
as a fly on the wall
with with us and our friend group i
think they would be surprised at how
serious we are how serious we are you
know it's like we
i mean we have a good time but it's not
like i i think
they may think that we would be on
but we're not and i think the thing is
is that if we
were as unserious
as we tend to be when we're in our
performance mode
all the time we can't live with
ourselves you wouldn't be watching
there would be no podcast there would be
no ethical entertainment that none of
this stuff that we've been doing for
over a decade would actually have
happened
which okay let's get into that because
this back to the website
this is a highly task oriented
relationship with both partners
driven to hard work and to be intensely
aware when
individually and collectively they are
not measuring up to their own
expectations and high standards
yeah so it goes without saying it's
pretty self-explanatory and very true of
both of us but i would say we push
ourselves and we i think
we're pretty good at supporting each
other like even in a recent conversation
we had i was talking to you
about like how sensitive i am to pulling
my weight
at this as i described a few weeks ago
we're at this
phase creative phase where a lot of
things are speculative
and we're just you know we're just
writing things we're just kind of
pursuing concepts we're not executing
and producing
as much or taking one project through
the whole thing
and i was kind of i was experiencing
uh just feeling like i i want to make
sure that
you know that i am sensitive to me
pulling my own weight and your response
was
well i'm not thinking about that because
you're thinking about
you holding yourself accountable to to
to what it is you want to achieve but so
we're both good at that we're both hard
on
ourselves yeah and we're actually not
that hard on each other i know that i
project that sometimes
uh but it's not actually the case
because
we drive ourselves so much yeah and and
we also have been in this relationship
for a very long time and in this
business relationship for a very long
time
so that there's this level of trust
where it's not i'm no longer like
we're not feeling it out anymore to be
like hey
what's he doing with his time you know
it's like there's nothing
both parties can bring selflessness
self-discipline
good work habits and the ability to put
aside their personal feelings for the
sake of the objective
good that needs to be done both types
are used to working so hard
that they often succeed garnering
admiration from those around them and
attaining places of leadership
and responsibility the one in three
combination
can be so dazzingly dazzlingly
accomplished
dyingly accomplished dazzlingly
accomplished dazzlingly
high energy extraordinarily competent
and impressive both individually
and collectively uh so we really
we really stumbled into something good
man
i mean it's not like when we were
in first grade we were looking through
the class to see who we could team up
with
to cr to create like a uh
a digital studio and aspire to a media
empire
in the future i mean i wasn't like who
can who can team up with me to make us
dazzlingly what
uh accomplished it's not like i didn't
say it three times
but i you know you know people ask the
question a lot of times now
and first of all we're going to get to
the bad parts of our relationship
and in the pitfalls of the three and the
one it would just it kind of starts with
a positive so we'll stay there for a
second
yeah let's dazzle a little man um
a lot of time you know a lot of people
are in this business that we're in
right um but uh
uh a minority of people who are in the
creator business
sort of take it to the level that we've
taken it to and i'm not
i'm not patting ourselves on the back
i'm just saying that like there's plenty
of creators who are just like
guys i don't want a company with a
hundred people that's not what i want i
just want to
create yeah and i think that maybe even
sometimes against our
own interests because we can we should
right we're just like this could get
bigger this could be more successful
yeah we could make this company bigger
we could have a bigger idea we could
take this further
and there's very little evaluation of
whether or not
we should it was it's just a given that
that's what's going to happen
and it's been that way since the
beginning and that's why it's continued
to grow because it's almost a maniacal
and sometimes pathological and
self-harming
um instinct to just keep pushing
because neither one neither person in
the relationship
they're now we'll talk about how the
threes and the ones balance each other
but neither one in the relationship is
really holding you back from
continuing to move forward in general
there could be some frustrations which
we'll talk about but
it isn't like the one is like i don't
want to move forward the one is like i
want to move forward but in a particular
way and the three is just like i want to
move forward because when we move
forward
we'll
um they both strive after excellence
both as an ideal
and as something to personally embody
sometimes they succeed so well
that this pairing virtually glows with
self-confidence and the thrill
of their own talents they strive to make
each other proud of them
someone the other can look up to and
show off to his or her friends and
family
they enjoy planning and organizing them
you know sometimes i invite you over and
i'm like
look at my friend they're right they
enjoy planning and organizing their
lives dividing up responsibilities after
seeing who is objectively better at
which tasks
both thrive on respect and give each
other personal space
so this idea and this is this is really
interesting it talks a little bit more
specifically about this in a second but
the idea
in comparison to you uh
in so much of my life is in relationship
to you and in contrast to you i've kind
of
given off this air of like i'm not i
don't really my life is not organized
i'm not a planner
link's the planner but again in the
spectrum of organization
and efficiency and planning and
pragmatism i'm actually i would say in
the top 10 percentile
of organized efficiency and i know this
because i live in a family of
all the my all the members of my family
are on the opposite end of the
spectrum and not my wife is perfect
example
not a planner not organized she's a
procrastinator
and yeah and she will gladly admit that
we both know our way around a
spreadsheet
it's just the fact that well i might be
in the top 10 percentile you're in the
top one percentile
you know what i'm saying so in contrast
there seems like a big difference
but we're both actually in this almost
engineering mindset
when we the way that we approach in the
way that we schedule things and this
whole idea about dividing things up
this is something that especially over
the past like five six years
right we've begun to get very just
because there's so many things going on
we had to do it out of necessity we have
these
meetings where we're like evaluating all
that's on our plate and it's just like
you take this i'll take this you take
this
i'll take this there are struggles
associated with like
dividing things up but but it's
overwritten
by there's like a there's a it's freeing
there's kind of comfort in knowing oh
yeah yeah it's like you can
you can take this i'll take and i'll
take this kind of a thing
right um as long as there's as
there's enough and there's things that
we can both
get excited about that are different
that's especially when it works
right which is what you were getting at
earlier yeah sometimes it doesn't
it's not that clean yeah there are only
two other equally goal
oriented pairings a one with a one
and a three with a three now i think i
experience a one with a one
because i think that stevie's a one i
think that stevie's a three
really yup wait i mean she i don't think
she's looked into this because she's not
and you know okay so i've always known
that she's into i've always thought that
stevie was a one
and then when i dove back into reading
about a three
i was like you know what i think that
stevie's a three
well only she can say for sure yeah and
and and
you shouldn't you shouldn't pigeonhole
somebody else you can't put you can't
put a number on somebody and that's why
it's up to her to
but it's interesting because but go
ahead because she definitely has one
tendencies and ones and threes can be
mistaken for each other a lot of times
yeah i think when it comes to like our
creative interactions
to me she feels more like the way that
i interact systematically
like if we're thinking about ideas i
tend to think of
structure first and like i i create
boxes to then
check it's like all right in order for
this to be a good idea it has to meet
these criteria and and
and sometimes we get so bogged down in
that
that we don't come up with any ideas
whereas
and and maybe that's less of a three one
thing and and just
more of a creative mindset going on but
like well
things like that she's very systematic
the reason i think that she's a three
uh is because no no offense to the ones
ones have a tendency to give superfluous
feedback
and stevie never gives superfluous
feedback and also
threes tend to have this almost
uh again to the detriment of their own
health
commitment to doing doing doing doing
doing and that's stevie
and and also threes have a tendency to
do things themselves
before they give you the opportunity to
do them yourself
i do that and stevie does stevie's
gotten better at that
because she's so good at so many things
the ones also do that
yeah so it's i but i do think
i mean when you when you add her into
the mix you see how it still
works because it's it's it's within this
framework that you and i
and whether she's a one or a three it
still it works the three of us
together create this um it's like a pr
it's like approaching a tornado i
believe that i could imagine what it
would be like for somebody
on the outside if we were in the middle
of a creative process
to be like i don't i don't know how to
step into this tornado i feel like if i
step into it i might get hit by a piano
do you know what i'm saying because
there's an intensity i would love to do
the process i would love to know because
i'm then i start to think i wonder what
jacob is like stevie works so closely
with jacob
and then i start to think i think jake
was the one i start to think
you know it's like maybe maybe we need
to drop everything and everybody needs
to go every
all right we did strengthsfinder at one
point a long time ago
okay so goal oriented pairings the one
and the one and three and three
although since these both are same type
pairings they typically have blind spots
that these combinations
will need to be aware of because the one
three is a mixed pair
this produces a powerful coalition that
is capable of dealing both with
ideals and with practical matters
they will try to solve problems in the
relationship by discussing the issues
involved
since neither likes emotionally charged
bickering or unresolved issues
so we can talk about that because this
is something that i mean
again these are a lot of these are
principles that would
it be true to any personality
combination
but we have had sort of a
hypersensitivity to
having the conversation about the
conversation to having the meta
conversation about our
relationship and it usually we're both
so busy and so focused
that sometimes more time than needs to
pass
passes before we have another one of
those conversations
that's a conversation about our
relationship
yeah this is something that happens on a
very regular basis and
in the friendships and the business
relationships
that we have sort of been exposed to
uh that's the advice we always give is
that you got to have a conversation
about the conversation you got to talk
about your relationship
and i my uh instinct or my
my observation is that a lot of people
have not made the decision to have the
conversation about their relationship
and it has not worked out
yeah i mean the the thing that strikes
me about everything that we've read is
that it
i mean it it resonates so much with
us in a professional setting and like
having these
dreams that we want to accomplish and
goals that we're going after
like so for like it's a good combination
for people starting up
starting a business or or working
closely in partnership
now i mean the enneagram institute makes
a point that
like if you're talking about any type of
relationship it you can make any
combination
work it's not like well you shouldn't
you shouldn't be in business with
with if you're a certain number you
should only be business with other
numbers no that's not the case
it's just there's certain strengths and
certain pitfalls with all the
combinations
and also with um you know relational i
think
it's just huge in marriage which we'll
get to in a second but exactly
it doesn't mean you can't be in a
marriage or a relationship or a business
partnership with another number
it's just it brings a level of awareness
to and i guarantee
you that nine times out of ten if you
were like my
i'm a so-and-so and my wife is so-and-so
i'm so-and-so my business partners are
so-and-so
and then you read about these and you're
like oh damn we always go back to these
same trouble spots
and i think for well we haven't even
started reading the trouble spots but i
do think that
we have a tendency to get so focused on
on the goals
and that we're headed towards that we
couldn't neglect
our friendship the health of it and
that's specifically listed in here and i
feel like
we're doing good if we have the
conversation about the conversa
how we converse and how we relate
once a quarter but then if it
if it goes to only twice a year or once
a year then
those conversations get to they they
tend to take a lot of
time and then you get and we do get
through it because it's it's
it's the same conversation you know it's
just
you know oh it's just it's nine months
later than the
the last time we had it right one step
three is to be more grounded and
realistic
three's help one stretch themselves and
not be so perfect perfectionistic
they are both industrious and persistent
efficient
and concerned with excellence and with
making a real difference in the world
i mean again this is like i feel like
somebody is reading the
exact this is they're reading our mail
well let's talk about the trouble spots
though
yeah tim we've congratulated ourselves
enough even for a three
i'm so dazzled i need to take some of
the sheen off
if this relationship gets into trouble
it is often
over time commitments lack of emotional
attachment to each other
and a creeping sense of competition now
as you remember very well we did a whole
um we did a whole episode where i was
accusing you of being as competitive as
me
uh and i again i regret some of the
things that i said and the stance that i
took
in that but i do think that and again i
think that we're learning more about
what what's going on inside your mind
when you do things that
externally present themselves as
competitive yeah
um but that whole pulling
each other's weight and um
pulling pulling your pulling pulling
your hip pulling your own weight
and like the don't pull my weight the
balance
that we have in the things that we do
yeah
um definitely speaks to this
we both are like i don't okay we're
doing a meeting where we're talking to
everybody in the company well i want 50
of the words
don't you you know what i'm saying and
it's like there's always been this just
like
okay i'll take this point then you take
this point i'll take this point we just
divide everything up
in that way yeah and as we talked about
in that competition discussion
which by the way was never we never knew
we were going to have it
it just happened uh it was
but that was an interesting that was an
interesting moment
but yeah i was just trying to explain
like okay if you take our
the meaning it's like we yeah we set up
this system where
it's we're going to divide up how we're
going to present everything
to all of our employees and then that
becomes
a and to me the reason is
uh it's a it's valued
to present a united front and for them
to hear from both of us
and kind of you know know where we're
coming from yeah and then there's
certain things that one of us can
uh feel more passionately about or can
communicate more concisely
or more effectively so there's a there's
a divide and conquer type thing
and then all of it in my mind goes into
the definition of what means the meeting
went well
when it's over and i'm analyzing it the
second
we turn off the the camera
on the video try to walk out of the room
when we get back into the board room
right i hesitate to then say and i think
you think this way
because i also think we tend to
characterize the other person's motives
it's really hard to do that because our
motives are so different
that it's very easy to mischaracterize
in a way that seems like well for me
that i'm being critical of you
yeah and you might uh try to
characterize my motives in a way
that seems again you would have to say
is it competitive is there more of a
comparison there it's like
i i think that i well
we'll get into that in a second when we
talk about how threes respond to ones
and ones respond to threes
okay but my and i think where my mind is
out
at after a meeting like that is not and
i think this is pretty
you know enlightening given
what you just said is you said you can't
you're immediately analyzing how the
meeting went
and what i am analyzing is what
our people think about us as leaders
the meeting is a sort of a conduit
for them to perceive us in the right way
as leaders
right yeah that's what the three goes to
the three goes to is
how did we and how did i individually
no i'm not it's not just like how did i
i'm not
i'm mature enough at this point for it
not to be
how did i come across versus link
it's more how did we come across as
leaders
did we did we put a picture out there
and again there's the whole
there's this deception thing which the
three deals with which is
we kind of just pass right over whether
or not we are good leaders
and get right into do people think we're
good leaders because that's what's
really important right and again this is
not a conscious process this is like
this
intuitive emotional sort of under the
surface thing that if i really step back
and think about where my
mind was after a meeting i'm like oh i
was actually
hoping that our employees would walk
away from this
meeting and think these guys are engaged
these guys
these guys care about us and that you
know they're giving they're
putting you know uh establishing a great
vision for our company and
thumbs up to those guys good good good
leaders good bosses
and and all of that resonates with me
but i go back to the the way that i know
that we've gotten there
is by measuring the process the
the process right and i think it's more
about the specifics
i think it's more about the performance
right
and again the funny thing is is that
when you sit and look at the external
execution it's a pretty
pretty similar external yeah result
you know what i'm saying what we do it
we do have
your ultimate goal is not to look good
is to do the things that
yeah and my ultimate goal is not to have
a perfect meeting our ultimate goal
is to uh lead
wisely yeah but my belief my underlying
belief my orientation in the world
is that a big part of effective
leadership
is them just thinking that we're good
leaders you know what i'm saying
like uh and i'm not saying that it's
true i think you need to you i'm not
actively trying to deceive and trying to
lie it's just
again i'm being vulnerable about the way
the threes work
okay so there's two sections here and
instead of this will take forever if we
go through
what i want to do is i want to read the
way
ones tend to think about threes which
would
get to this paragraph and then just let
you respond and say this resonates that
doesn't resonate and then we'll do the
same
okay ones tend to find threes too
workaholic
pragmatic and too concerned with their
image and their reputation
rather than with principle ones can see
threes is tending to cut corners and
ethical matters
willing to exaggerate or fudge the truth
in order to achieve whatever they're
after
they can also become critical of threes
if they change their goals pragmatically
dropping efforts or switching positions
when something does not work for them
ones may also have issues with threes
attempting to reinterpret ethical
questions
and with not owning up to their personal
behavior including their behavior
regarding fidelity
in the relationship itself all of the
middle part
about like are you are you
deceitful are you doing things
underhanded are you are you lying to
people
or do you do i question your integrity
it's like no no
um you know we're both we're both good
boys
as your mom would say and my nana would
say y'all are such good boys
you work so hard i'm so proud of y'all
that's what what
nana says but i mean the very beginning
the very first thing and the very last
thing resonates so the very first thing
of like
okay is he doing this for effect
because you know to uh image management
i think that that that comes up for me
yeah and
and this is why when we go back to that
that conversation about competition
you tend to uh
analyze someone else's behavior
according to the way that you're
thinking about it
so in other words like what we talked
about before like
if you come to work with a weird pair of
pants on
and it's like those pants are short and
baggy yeah and you know objectively
they don't look good is what i'm
thinking right okay but
they are quirky and cool and fashion
forward
and so what i interpret is
link is trying to seam fashion forward
so again because if i were to put those
pants on
i would be doing it the same fashion
forward right
i would be doing it to maintain an image
of like hey i'm trying i'm mixing things
up and
look at what look what rhett's doing now
about his
appearance in some way oh rhett grew his
hair out
he must be doing that because he wants
to be a guy with long hair
right and i have something i definitely
fight against
in myself but then i interpret any
choice that you make in the same way
i i think this this gets to the
to the thing that i thought was the
moment in last week's podcast
and maybe it wasn't it so i'll just
throw this out there
uh the thing that
rubbed me the wrong way was
i yeah i felt like
the kind you know the typically an ear
biscuit conversation
is more of a conversation but because
it's more because of the way that we set
up last week
and we're bouncing back and forth and we
each have things that we want to convey
um you you directed more of the things
that you were saying
to the audience than to me and
uh you know there's two things
one i've i i recognize that
kind of rubbed me the wrong way because
i was like
is like he seems really caught up in
in really getting something across and
is that
i don't know is that related to what you
were saying about
then how you would be perceived you know
i the thing that i've
i've said for years like people like
what's your pet peeve about rhett and i
say well
he he's a know-it-all you know it prick
it pricked that
uh pet peeve again because
and i was i was thinking well maybe
there's an image management part of it
like he's got this thing that he
he wants to come across in a certain way
and i could be totally wrong it's just i
was in my own head about it
but i and i think the bigger thing and
maybe it's because i think that may have
been smaller and maybe i'm even reaching
okay because i'm i get a little nervous
kind of putting that on you because
none of that may be true but i know the
part about me
is that there's this
uh you know
i took it personally that you didn't
want to talk to me you didn't want to
talk to me about this
like there was some uh what was the last
thing you read because the word was an
abandonment but there's definitely
an abandonment well the thing yeah that
comes a little bit later and
and that's that that's in play for once
and definitely for me
you know if you look at um my childhood
and it's like okay my dad wasn't there i
got a
i got a great relationship with my dad
now i i don't like
throwing him under the bus but you know
it
it it happened and i think there was a
seed of
it you know i really respond to that of
like
if if you're asserting yourself or your
point of view
and i just and i disappear am i going to
be left behind or am i going to
in this conversation or work or
relationally really it feels like a
relational
abandonment when he's not talking to me
anymore he's talking to them it's like i
might as well not even be here right
well okay so it's crazy how we're about
to address these exact the
same things but what i'll say is i mean
first of all
so long as there is a camera on me i am
thinking about the audience for sure
right and it also
in in a negative way being a three
being a performer who actually has an
audience who actually has a camera on
him
all the time right if you there's not a
day that passes that you can't go on the
internet and see something new
that i'm in so there is this image that
exists of me that's been built
over over a over a long time over a
decade
and it is
if i was only concerned about my
personal health like if that was
if the only motivation in life was
personal health i would stop all this
i i i would i would be like i need i
need to have no image i need to have no
social media i need to have absolutely
no interaction with an audience at all
i need to go to a monastery shave my
beard
shave my hair and live in a robe with a
bunch of
other dudes who kind of look exactly
like me um
now there's other things in life i think
what we're doing
i think what we're doing creatively is
awesome i think that what we're doing as
a company and the things that we want to
do in the world are great and i'm not
gonna and don't worry i'm not about to
stop doing that but i'm just saying that
so that's a constant thing that i'm
thinking about and battling is
my demons right
but i think another big i think one of
the reasons that
uh i tend to i mean it differs but
in this context one of the reasons i'll
talk to the audience is because the same
reason that
when we did our deconstruction stories
i tended to kind of talk about the
thought process that i had gone through
and kind of talked about it in a
persuasive way even when i'm trying
actively to not be persuasive
and to try to bring you onto my team and
try to get you to think like me
i tend to just present everything as if
i'm trying to convince you of something
yeah threes are the ultimate persuaders
right and so we just can't help it we
speak
in a persuasive way now when it comes to
the enneagram there's a practical side
to it which is
you already know all this stuff right
and so i feel like the audience is
listening into
a conversation about us and they're
getting they've been asking for this
conversation about the enneagram
you haven't been asking about it because
you we've been talking about it on our
own personally for years
so i think i tend to just direct my
attention to the audience because it's
just like hey this is
you know this is new information for you
but
let me read through the ways threes tend
to find ones because it's going to talk
about what you just did and then i will
tell you exactly the thing that i was
hinting at
earlier which is kind of related to what
you just said
on the other hand threes tend to find
ones too rigid
and judgmental in their attitudes and
inflexible
in various areas while threes generally
value one's organizational ability and
ability to get things done
threes can feel that ones are too
narrow-minded and methodical
too perfectionistic and focused on
details rather than results
we don't need to get into that you
already know that that's that's
something that we talk about a lot but
threes may have issues with ones about
feeling they are
being stifled or judged both for their
attitudes and for their actions
so i'll stop here because
i think that that was the only issue i
had with the last podcast
was in my mind
what i have been doing throughout the
conversation
and again i'm not saying i don't fall
into the trap of image management and i
gladly
readily admit that it's probably never
going to go away
but what i is but then i spent some time
talking about like
being in the feeling triad and being
like i know y'all don't think i'm
i feel anything you i know y'all think
i'm insensitive i'm actually feeling a
lot of things
and i'm just coming to grips with the
fact that i'm feeling all these things
and that was one of the things i spent
some time talking about
and so then at the end of the
conversation you were like
seems like you were pretty concerned
about like correcting some
misconceptions about you
right and you said and so the way i felt
in that moment
was judged right i was like i made a
decision to be vulnerable
right i made a decision to kind of go a
little bit deeper and pull the curtain
back in a way that's
vulnerable and kind of exposing myself
and saying that like yeah i have this
inner
performer who's constantly trying to put
the best foot forward
who's feeling a lot of things who's
figuring these things out who's going to
therapy for these things
and then you kind of took the
opportunity to be like it seems like
you're
managing managing your image right now
right and so
the judgment and i yeah and i
i think that was my yeah so you know i'm
sorry for that
because the one thing that i did think
about because again on my car right back
i'm like
you know what at that point where rhett
was like really getting worked up about
how
he doesn't feel like he's worthy like i
wish i would have said
you're worthy i wish i would have just
stated it and i felt like
yeah this is another point where it's um
i think i was
i was being critical of like
as we weren't the the episode wasn't
going the way that i wanted to go
conversationally it was
when things get more presentational it
it
it doesn't um
that's not a mode when i feel like i can
contribute
to making a good product i can make a
good episode
so i think there's some underlying
things there that i was like
i was starting to get frustrated that
like
this isn't going well because it's just
we're not listening to each other we're
both just taking turns
saying whatever we thought we needed to
say about ourselves
and a good air biscuit is when we
connect with each other
and if we don't meet that criteria i
start to get frustrated
and i was like he's not listening to me
but i'm also not listening to him
and it's just you know this must just
totally suck
and then i'm like i'm just gonna i'm
gonna throw something out there
that is going to uh
i think part of it was a dig because i
was frustrated
and then part of it was a way to
at least it was like i'll throw
something juicy out there that he can
respond to
that'll that'll get us out of our notes
and it was
so it was manipulative so you know i
i tend when things don't go right i tend
to like i said sing
sink my teeth and my claws into and
start to control
what's happening in order to right the
ship to fix things
uh but i'd you know i'd
i'll admit there was like i was i was
starting to like feel a little
hurt there was like some emotion there
and ag and again it was like
that's not really i think everything you
said and explain to where you're coming
coming from without how you're
presenting information and stuff like
that
my growth is in terms of our
relationship one of the things is trying
to
celebrate your strength even if i'm not
an active part of it in that moment like
if there's
moments in a podcast where you can
play to the strength of presenting
information and being persuasive
or taking a risk and being vulnerable
that's actually what you were doing
there but my i was in such a
headspace that by that point i wasn't
listening enough to appreciate that
that's what you were doing
you know i was so i was kind of writing
you off
all of these things were going on in my
head but it's not and
and then it comes across as judgment so
the last thing i'm trying to say right
now is
i admit that those things were you know
i was judging the episode and i was
i was also doing the other things i've
already said
uh but you i i understand you weren't
you weren't doing you weren't doing
anything to dig me like whenever
you look at your notes or you decided to
address the audience directly
that like it's nowhere on your radar
that that would hurt my feelings
and i also know it actually shouldn't
hurt my feelings
it should be something that i should i
should celebrate
because it's at moments where we can
lean into our strengths
we should both do that you know yeah and
you know to be clear
the only reason i brought it up is is
because of the way that
it's so perfectly speaking you should i
know but i think you should have brought
it
well you can say that it hurt your
feelings well no it can also that could
also be a reason to bring it up well i
know it did
because you because like you said you
took a risk but yeah but
you're being vulnerable i just want to
be clear that it that
it wasn't like i mean this is a tendency
this is a tendency in our relationship
and something that
we have you know
comes up from time to time where i'm
like i kind of feel judged for
thinking that or doing that in that way
but it but it's also something that i'm
very aware is a dyna it's a personality
dynamic so i don't spend a lot of time
like letting resentment build up it was
it was
more like oh this is actually as i read
through this i was like this is a good
opportunity to bring that up as an
illustration
i'm not yeah of course what i'm getting
at is
yes i hurt my feelings it didn't hurt my
feelings and to such a degree
that i was like apart from us doing this
second part of the podcast i would have
never said anything about it
i think i mean right or wrong i would
have never said anything about it i
don't know that that's a good thing
so i mean you see i so i don't think
that redeems
anything no i actually think
i mean don't you think growth for you is
is is confronting me about it well yeah
but the point i guess the point is is
that because that's
those feelings if every single time i
felt judged
by you i said that hurts my feelings and
brought it up we would never get
anything done
and which is exactly what's like that's
what i'm saying too every
every single time that i feel like
something you do that has a
a side effect of it that it it pricks my
insecurities
you know i shouldn't point that out
to you even because that's for me to
work out
it's it's you're not doing anything
wrong
but i think if if there was a little
part of that that got a little tense
because maybe i was
maybe i was doing something wrong ones
tend to
search for things to confess so that
they can get the criticism out of the
way too so maybe i'm also doing that
maybe um but let me i want to finish
reading this paragraph three c ones
critiques of them
well threes thrive on praise but
stressed ones are unable to give any
credit to themselves much less to anyone
else
three c one's critiques of them is
nitpicking and time wasting
so again i think one of the things that
happens with me is if like you're going
to critique me or something like that
like what i did in the moment is you
said
it seems like you're protecting your
image or whatever and i and i just
owned it and said yeah i'm all about
image management which was kind of a
joke but also kind of a confession like
yeah we've been talking about
that and yes that is an element of what
i've been doing
um but there's also but there's there's
also
a part of it that is just a general
vulnerability but it's the
that's the that's the crazy the crazy
internal battle is like
you make a decision to it's just like i
was talking about with meditation
the moment that i begin actually doing
meditation in the
right way and focusing on my breath and
not being preoccupied with the thought
is the moment that i begin observing
myself doing that and giving myself a
pat on the back and being like look at
you
look at you all the people who are
watching you meditate right now
which is no one you know what i'm saying
yeah so i'm constantly dealing with that
on this on this podcast as
any conversation that i'm in the moment
that i choose to be
uh oh a perfect example like
um you know we had christie's uh
birthday thing at your house
and jesse had the idea which is very
jesse idea a very two idea which is
let's go around and say
things that we like about christy yeah
some people are comfortable with that
and some people are not i'm not
information circles i'm typically not
comfortable with that i'm
i'm not i'm you would think that as a
three i would be comfortable receiving
it but i'm also not comfortable
receiving it in that context right
because it feels unwarranted and it
doesn't feel like i did anything to
receive the praise it just feels like
you're all gonna just sit here and tell
me things you like about me yeah because
that's
you're worthy without because i don't do
anything
yeah right if you want to talk about how
good my paella was or something like
that it's like okay i'm okay with that
but you just want to talk about me i'm
not
so but i have been in therapy
i have been you know i've been trying to
address these things and even before
therapy i was aware of some of these
tendencies i just couldn't
label them and analyze them in the right
way
but it was just like okay i want to say
something about christie that means
something to christy
but i also want to say something about
christy that no one else says about
christy right i want to say something
that's unique and original about christy
um and then in the moment of saying it
it's like
there's two things happening there's
like i am enjoying being able to tell
christy the things that i appreciate
about her because
that's meaningful to her she's enjoying
this she's not completely comfortable
with it either but she's
got she is becoming comfortable with it
and as we go
as we go around the circle and do it but
i'm also thinking i wonder how that
stacked up to what
everyone else said and then of course
when science mike went
it was just like he's on another level
of being able to deliver that
he's like in his absolute element
oh yeah like he pulls things out in
these africa if he wants to
he gave in and that he gave three
analogies
like there was a sunrise analogy a tree
a tree analogy and
i don't know a wolf and a wolf but the
crazy thing i mean in fairness he did go
last which
that was that was no but like and and of
course but he probably could have gone
first and
what am i thinking in that moment i'm
like damn mike is so good at this i'll
never be as good as he is
at that well i'm the one that everybody
made fun of when it was over
i mean i think that my wife is hot and
fun
[Music]
i mean i could go into a lot of other
things and did i
did well did i think about it the rest
of the night her defense yes
in her defense you misspoke a little bit
and you were talking about when y'all
met and you said you were hot and fun
it's what you said and i know that's not
what you meant but that's what happened
trust me i know
that's what everybody likes you know
what christie never said anything but
i've been
she knows you very well and she knows
how to appreciate the things that you
have that you that you bring to the team
she's so hot and fun now um two
okay uh but okay getting into the one
the
one thing like the very next sentence is
eventually threes start to avoid ones
uh because there's so much nitpicking
and criticism
then that triggers one's abandonment
issues
which triggers more anger and criticism
which is exactly what happened during
the podcast yes
so you felt like i was abandoning you by
talking to the audience
and you judged me it felt abandoned and
then you criticize me and
and also but also my definition of a
good episode
is when we connect and they're just
listening in
and you know and plus i don't have
i don't work in that mode of talking to
the audience i'm i don't feel like i'm
good at presenting information
so it's like i then i'm i'm left out
you are good at acknowledging
and taking into account the audience in
a lot of
in different other other mediums like
okay this is what what is the camera
seeing right now i'm going to look into
this camera it's like i'm kind of like i
don't care about looking in that camera
well the the work that i'm doing on
if we talk about good mythical morning
is like
i believe that the show is its best when
we
are at most ourselves in connecting with
each other and
being as honest having the most honest
fun we can have
but ironically the more
so the more that i assert control the
harder that is
to happen like when i can just go with
the flow is
is is when it starts to work yeah and um
so that's my work is reminding myself of
that i mean if
just a couple of notes i made about
my my growth is
the more that i understand
myself it's like not taking those things
too seriously like using humor
to lighten up about my tendencies
my perfectionism um
so starting to harness those
eccentricities for comedy
uh it allows me to acknowledge
that it's a bit ridiculous and that it's
a bit overboard
and that it's that's what makes it funny
and so it disarms it
some within within myself and i actually
think that you harness
in terms of growth you harness your
tendencies for comedy too when it's like
you know the whole [ __ ] artist thing
where like you're really
just just making something up and
like that's that's harness that might be
harnessing
um you know image management
or just being able to pres
that whole deceit thing like it sounds
so nasty
but you found a way to turn that into an
a comedic angle and i
that's just something i thought of i
don't know how
on the show or in terms of comedy if
there's if you're
able to to to use that as your path for
growth well
i i i well i thought i don't necessarily
think it's a path for growth but i do
think that
the uh the three's ability
something i read in one of the books was
that um
threes are the best of any of the
numbers at reading a room
and like knowing this is what's required
in this space
right now to rise to the top to rise to
the top right
um so one of the things that ends up
happening is just like
i i feel like i could hang out with
anybody any group of people and kind of
assimilate right so there's one thing
about sort of assimilating and then sort
of figuring out what is the pecking
order in this group and again this is a
subconscious thing this isn't something
that
i don't manipulate you know to have this
like manipulative
uh strategic mindset it's just you find
yourself just oh
that's what happened i saw when i got
into that group so i think in comedy
just the ability to uh
know the mode that we're in and again
like i have to commit to it but if
oh i'm gonna commit to being this guy
that doesn't believe that finland exists
i can go i can go all the way right
and you might actually at the end think
maybe feeling doesn't exist
a couple other things in terms of my
growth in oneness you know they talk
about a one can move
to two every number can move to two
different numbers
in growth so a one can move forward
growth and stress
one is good and one is bad oh okay one
is one is the integration one is
disintegrating okay so i can move
forward to a
four and for me that's pursuing artistic
expression
without evaluation right you know so i
mean we pursue so much artistic
expression
but i evaluate all of it so it's
actually
saying well i'm just going to sit over
here and i'm going to doodle just for
the hell of it
and bad example but you know looking for
those things
and then talking about a one moving back
to a seven
there is a positive spin um
on that 2b growth which is to reclaim a
playful and spontaneous
impulse of childhood which again i think
that's
that's kind of the best vibe of good
mythical morning when
when i'm able to do that to to give
myself freedom to say
the best thing i can do here is to not
control and not
analyze and think about is everything in
the right place
on the desk is everything is this moving
at a fast enough pace or is this episode
going to be too long
when i start trying to be a producer i'm
doing
other people's jobs and i'm no longer
doing
the job that only i can do which is be
like unhinged me in the moment
listening and i think everyone will
agree that that's the
from an entertainment standpoint that's
the link that we all
want yeah and it's so i know that my
tendency
is to not do that so it's like whether
it's
in gmm or in my entire life just working
hard to relax more
you know uh make room for pleasure don't
fix things that don't need
fixing um
and as we've talked about on other
podcasts treat myself with the same
kindness and respect that i show to
others
and have this question in my mind of
do i want to be right or do i want to be
happy
and or even if i want to make a really
good product that means letting go
i it's it's great that we have a team
and we've we've set up an environment
where
i can actually like if i'm
the healthier i am the better it is yeah
and that's what's so tricky as we talk
about the the growth and the stress for
a three
so for you your growth
uh for whatever reason directly feeds
into
you being uh
you know more fun more spontaneity
spontaneous
uh spontaneous and a and b you become a
better performer
but my problem is being a performer
right so
that's why many entertainers are threes
lots of actors are threes because they
know how to get into a situation and
assume an identity right they're the
masters at it
and so uh they actually
are rewarded in entertainment by
detaching from their
authentic self and becoming something
that somebody else wants them to be
so that's the irony in what we do as
entertainers is that
i could actually be really good at our
job and be very unhealthy
because on the opposite end of the
spectrum
so the disintegration uh sort of the
stress arrow
for a three is to go to nine we become
disengaged and apathetic
uh which is like an unhealthy nine and
this doesn't happen many times in my
life but there are times when i feel
so overwhelmed so stressed out and
there's a common
theme with threes is they've worked so
hard that they become
physically ill right that's why i went
to therapy because of what was happening
with my eye and my back and all that
stuff
yeah um but in in integration and growth
uh threes become more cooperative and
committed to others like healthy sixes
so again threes tend to be just
ruthlessly independent and
not have time for people we don't have
time for relationships we don't have
time
for people and and this can be of great
detriment to friendships
and marriages right my wife because
those are people yeah
we're not it looks like we're not gonna
necessarily have time to talk about
the threes and the how the three
interacts with the twos but
i mean basically you can give them a
little we can give them a little bit of
um
okay so twos i mean i cut the other one
short because of the dentist
two is what my wife is so twos
fundamentally feel that threes put work
and career before them
their children and home life primarily
uh primary values values for twos
they feel that threes are too focused on
success and that they are missing the
really valuable things in life
freeze on the other hand can feel
stifled by the two's insistence on the
need to spend time together
threes field twos are smothering and
emotionally manipulative making them
feel guilty for working hard and making
the most of themselves
now this is a generalization of course
but this is the thing that jesse and i
end up
fighting about right because again i go
on vacation
and i'm not present i'm not it takes me
three days before i can be present on a
vacation
and even then if you give me a little
bit of time alone i'm going to be
writing something
i'm going to be coming up with an idea i
can't it's just i and
and i've talked to my therapist about
this and he's like well first of all you
don't need to judge
you don't need to judge yourself for
going into creative mode if you're
because you are also a naturally
creative person
and that's something that brings you joy
and you're learning how to become even a
better
more efficient channel at kind of
receiving ideas and bringing them into
the world
but you have to know when to turn that
off and when to turn that on
and if it's specifically happening to
the detriment of
you being present with your wife and
being present with your family then
it's a problem you need to turn off and
focus on them because
ultimately like i said last night last
time for me it's
i'm do do do do do and i need to be b
b b i need to be present and
specifically it's kind of ironic since i
talked about this
being the reason that i grew my hair out
and what i was trying to do in therapy
and that was before i even really
understood how
important this was to a three but this
is from the wisdom of the enneagram
the goal of the three is to connect with
the heart when they are able to
reconnect with their hearts healthy
threes model the essential gift of
authenticity like no
other type their behavior becomes
genuine not trying to be more or less
than they really are they become simple
and available revealing their true
selves with honesty
and humility again this whole idea of
not being concerned with what
you think and what the image is not over
identifying with the image that i am
projecting into the world and just be
like who actually
am i you know we don't threes a lot of
times we don't even know what we want
because we've made a game of our entire
lives of figuring out what you want and
figuring out a way to to bring it to you
and so
i have to be able to stop be like i
don't have to do anything right now
i can just be i could be present and
being present
in relationship with the people that you
know that's going back to that sixth
thing
being available doing something for
someone
not just doing something for someone
because it makes me
like again everything that i do
i can make it about me or i can make it
about you
i love to cook for people i'm
discovering that cooking for people
brings me joy
when everyone is sitting there eating
and they're like this is great
it brings me joy but the unhealthy and
there's a healthy
service in that it's like bringing joy
to people and creating environments
where people can
have truly joyful experiences of eating
food and having great company
that's all great all positive what i
have to resist is that now
you think something about me because i
made this for you right
that's the constant battle but it
doesn't mean don't do things for people
in fact the more i can in fact the more
you can choose to do things for people
where it involves kind of
folding in and doing something that's
not about bringing
attention where you're not doing
something special where she's like hey
i'm just going
building this house with these folks and
i'm do i'm i'm got a hammer and that
guy's got a hammer and no one's
no one's in charge i mean there's
another person who's in charge it's not
me
so kind of folding in and and being with
people serving alongside people those
are things that are good for me to kind
of
get out of that performance mentality um
was there anything else in relating to
jesse because i think it's
you kind of you kind of hit him maybe i
mean i
the the one thing that we've always
talked about is how
jesse is sort of the personal
personable one in our relationship and i
kind of a long time ago it's like
jesse's going to be the one who's going
to like talk to people and
you know if we have somebody staying
with us like she'll stay up and talk to
him i'll go
i'll go to bed because somebody's gonna
do it and it's like twos in particular
bring a more personal
individual focus to their interactions
with others they are thoughtful and
follow up exchanges with genuine
kindness and compassion
threes bring flexibility charm
practicality and goal-oriented vision
for ways the couple can improve twos
like to feel proud of their loved ones
and threes want to make their partner
proud
i think you you know you have a good you
have a
that's the you throw a good party for
that reason
yeah you know and the the to the two
three combination
is like the most um
socially i don't know what the word was
but basically
exactly what you just said they're gonna
be the couple
who's gonna throw a party and everyone's
gonna have a good time because the two
both the two
and the three are both image conscious
and so they're actually thinking about
how good is the party that we're gonna
throw and if you've got two people who
are committed to each other in this way
or where it's like
you know we're going to do an awesome
party for everybody
and it might there might be some
unhealthy motivation in there which is
because people will think we're great
the benefit to
being friends with twos and threes is
that well there's going to be a great
party
you know what i'm saying right um for me
and christy
she's a six uh so ones and sixes both
excel at analytical thinking and both
worry about things going wrong
ones tend to feel anxious about making
mistakes and sixes tend to feel
general anxiety related to many things
potentially going wrong in life
so for christy she gets worried about
the things that she can't control
and i i only worry about the things that
i can control i've got an assignment
i've got a test i've got
this thing i need to do planes
christy hates planes because
she has no control and there is a she
can she can visualize
a worst case scenario even if the movie
playing on the plane is not about a
plane crash
she can she she's watching it right um
but for me i love plane flights because
there's nothing i can do right yeah and
i ignore the fact that there's wi-fi on
a plane now
like i don't even want to have wi-fi i
love the fact that you put me in this
shell where it's like for x number of
hours
i can't do anything i'm just like i'm
not being measured to anything i'm
sitting here
and i can i can read i can listen i can
think
i think so freely on a plane and then i
look over at christy and she's like
shaking this is a great idea for if
not a book like how each number
approaches a flight
there's so much in that because the way
a three approaches the flight is i'm
like
okay i'm flying across the country i got
four and a half hours what am i gonna
accomplish
you know what can i come up with right
in this four and a half hours and i'm
like and if i can
i can finally relax and if i make the
choice
to watch the movie and not write i think
that i'm worthless i feel bad about
myself um
and also i don't talk to anybody next to
me whereas a two
jessie she'll start she'll start a
conversation with somebody like oh
[ __ ] she's talking to somebody yeah for
i mean christy and i both have a strong
sense of duty and honor we like showing
up on time we like following the rules
we both love um organization
and cleanliness having our house in
order
a lot of these very practical things
about putting our lives together
systematically um
she has a it gives her a sense of
security
and and it gives me a sense of
um control that like this is
i i can i can perfect this because
i'm i can control it and
so that really plays out really well
practically we don't argue about those
things like a lot of those
pet peeves at home type stuff we're
almost always on the same page
and you know i was giving myself a hard
time of like um
not allowing myself to just just fall in
love with christy
and that be enough for us to be together
i was so
i had to have all the right answers and
be able to to defend my decision to
propose
with data but i do think i was picking
up on
our compatibility as ones and sixes when
it comes to a lot of
the practicalities yeah the things that
we'll argue about
um now ones will come to decisions
quickly
because we're more sure of ourselves and
our opinions and tens
sixes tend uh to be unsure because
there's so many things that could go
wrong
so there's there's the indecisiveness
sixes bring a warmth and more emotional
responsiveness and availability
so there is a bit of that like what what
you you were describing with you and
jesse there's some of that
with me and christy too in terms of like
uh that emotional responsiveness
and being able to being able to be
warmly connect with people yeah is is
something that she really helps me with
but sharing burdens and chores that's
totally equal
both are steadfast loyal and faithful to
each other wanting to build a solid
foundation together both can count on
the other
and that gives both of us room to relax
and but sometimes my criticisms
can fuel uh her six insecurities
in our relationship so there's there's
in the same kind of like our dynamic
i can kind of push her away with
perceived criticism right
even more to myself but it's people only
hear that
no it's perceived as a threat so we have
to work through well you talk about the
whole like initial
sort of attraction uh compatibility
thing and again
not to say that any number can be
compiled in compatible
i mean like some are going to be more
challenging if you're both eights
like that's gonna be a challenging
relationship i mean
but there's all kinds of different
challenges two and a three so jesse
tells the story so again the three is
the performer and the two
is the the helper and again there's
better ways to describe that but that's
how it's often described
um one of the ways that this sort of
works out is the three loves being in
the spotlight and the two loves
having someone who's in the spotlight
that they can put into the spotlight
and jesse remembers uh pretty much the
one of the first times we ever
interacted with each other you know we
had met like at church
one time or whatever i ended up inviting
her up to
the campus crusade meeting which i was
emceeing and i knew i would be emceeing
it and not only that it was one of those
uh it was one of those those times where
we had made a video
where it was me going and finding greg
somewhere on campus and like bringing
him into the thing
yeah and uh and so there was this video
that played and then i like
danced down the aisle and then took the
microphone and started speaking to
everybody
and she tells the story of like
that's very attractive to a two
this guy just came in and like performed
for a few hundred people and danced down
the aisle and then took the thing and
started doing a monologue and
that was like the moment that she
started to fall in love with me
good bad or indifferent what the reasons
are but like she was attracted to
that and then once i saw the way that
she
responded to me exerting myself in the
in in those places i was like oh she
likes this
specifically she exactly she's a she
is a fan of what i'm doing and she
appreciates it right and again there
there's it could this could seem very
shallow but it there's actually this
whole idea of the two
so you uh this this is like a lot of
political
honestly a lot of political couples are
the politician is a three and the spouse
is a two
um i'm i think barack and michelle are
or this combination but the but there
but the
the um i thought michelle was a
one yeah maybe they're not no she's
maybe she's a three but the they may
both be threes
but the uh this has been a source of
strength in our relationship
but the thing that has been a source of
strife at the same time is the fact that
twos actually
also want to be the center of attention
right
and jesse jesse was a performer like she
she was she was on stage she's always
been a performer
and so there's a resentment that can
build
um when you get into a relationship and
the three continues to sort of exert
themselves and kind of
be in the spotlight and the two is doing
is loves the fact that they've got
somebody who's in the spotlight
somebody they can be proud of and
somebody that they can keep pushing into
the spotlight
and first of all as i've said many times
jessie was
is a huge reason that i'm doing what i'm
doing she
directly encouraged me to pursue this
career
and along the way has kind of directed a
lot of the
decisions that i've made and but she can
also tweet
but she wants she but as a two she wants
credit for that
naturally she wants she wants credit for
that and so
if it gets to a point where i feel if i
start to be like well
i'm the one who's doing all the cool
stuff and you're supporting me in that
and that's actually the way that i would
communicate that then the relationship
begins to disintegrate
we both have to give each other our
props in other words you know in in
a healthy a healthy way and if we don't
do that
then these these can become very toxic
that's where the
the two and the three becomes very toxic
if they're competing
if they're competing for attention and
they're both unhealthy
thankfully we've we've been aware of
this dynamic and
have been able to harness it and and uh
and jesse of course is also in therapy
and dealing with
all her own [ __ ] too and so we both are
able to
um you know have a healthy marriage for
20 years
michelle obama is a one by the way and
josh groban is a two
oh so this is the josh groban barack
obama relationship i know i can't
remember
there's a two three relationship that is
in some book and i can't remember who it
is
um okay we we should wrap this up huh
we did it we did the enneagram episode
i've got a wreck um
there's you know so much of this
enneagram stuff can be
the test and it can be pretty heady and
i wanted to recommend
uh an episode of a podcast called
sleeping at last
sleeping at last is the moniker of
according to his website chicago-based
singer-songwriter producer and composer
ryan o'neill he's friends of friends but
we've
we've never met and maybe it's better
that way this
um this dude he he
he has all these series on his podcast
which again is sleeping at last
but he had a sub series where he wrote a
song
for each number of the enneagram
and you can as you're digging into this
if you want
more of an artistic processing
something that's kind of it's more heart
first than kind of head first
way to approach it um the first song he
wrote
i mean it was back in october of 2017.
so if you just start sleeping at last
and then enneagram and your number
that the episode will pop will pop up
but
the one agent
elvis presley is a three and priscilla
was a two
oh elvis and person elvis and priscilla
that worked out well
yeah so if if you start sleeping at last
enneagram in your number
like for me one it'll pop up and
the song that he wrote
i hadn't listened to it in a couple of
years every time
i go back and listen to it like
you know i don't like using the phrase
but like i feel so seen
like it taps into the emotionality of
your number in a way that like
even sitting here on the website and
just reading the lyrics to myself
i can just feel my throat start to close
up like i'm about to burst into tears
well i was on the treadmill
at the gym with a lot of people
and jesse was like oh you got to listen
to the he just released the three song
i put the three song on it's amazing i
was weeping on the
treadmill i'm starting to just tear up
right now
not only is it incredible music uh but
and i think the three is the best song
but but also um everyone who contributes
musically on each song
is that enneagram well he goes through
the entire process
it's crazy and
but again it's like a different way into
experiencing
it's so such an empathetic treatment
of your number to feel like you're known
and accepted for this another way to
know it's another way to begin to
discover what you are
if you burst into you probably will if
you if you read the lyrics and you
understand the lyrics listen to the song
and it's like that's me you're probably
that number
hashtag ear biscuits um appreciate
all the enneagram conversation that's
happening
using that hashtag so uh let us know
how you how you're responding to this
and you know i
i feel i feel good i'm not gonna analyze
this thing
because well because i already have and
i feel great about this episode
i feel like at the end of every episode
could be linked to
are you cool with this one and i would i
would have an answer for you
uh this one's eight plus man you can
make all the comments you want
and it redeemed the last one which i
gave a d to
and i shouldn't have but i'm going to
resist the urge to go read the comments
because i don't want to find my
self-worth and your approval
oh snap we'll talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]